oh
new fingerprints detected the [ __ ]
increasing volume by 33
new fingerprints detected
what the hell are you user inquiry
technical specifications h j k
e 11 smart gun with built-in ai
experimental model
name skippy
guy by the dumpster that your owner
checking memory
resources available 100 all files
removed manually
possible cause theft original owner
no data suggested solution
none i got one i'll take you processing
request
no objections found
still got all your functions running
system diagnostics
testing will take approximately 47
seconds
what are you doing i'm making the weight
more pleasant with a soothing melody
test successfully completed the program
skippy version 0.01 alpha
is running correctly
all right so what can you do besides
talk my ear off
primary feature automated targeting in
case of critical threat to user
autonomous shooting capabilities please
choose one of two operating modes
first mode puppy loving pacifist i will
aim at the enemy's lower extremities
second mode stone cold killer i will aim
exclusively
at the head
uh guess i'll go with puppy loving
pacifist
adjusting settings
selected mode puppy loving pacifist
enjoy permanently crippling your enemies
error premature discharge i'm sorry
this never happens
you magazine detected message to user
thanks joey
[Music]
que pedo
foreign
oh
the vast majority of murders are
committed by men
just like you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
that's me
ah
foreign
um
[Music]
[Music]
you